hi everyone welcome to our daily
homeroom for those of you who are
wondering what this is this is something
that we started many months ago it was
really when all of us had to be socially
distanced around kovat but it's really
evolved into you know an outlet to
having interesting conversations and for
us to interact with all of y'all as we
go through the conversation I'm very
excited about our guests today feel free
to ask questions on Facebook and YouTube
and the message boards I have team
members who are looking at it and we
will try to surface as many questions as
possible but before we begin our
conversation I will give my standard
announcement reminder to everyone that
kind of Kadim you is a not-for-profit
that we exist because of philanthropic
donations from folks like yourself in a
position to do so please think about
donating a special shout out to several
corporations that stepped up as
especially as the kovat crisis was
ramping up in our servers our traffic
was to 250 percent 300 percent of normal
registrations were in through the roof
we're trying to accelerate a bunch of
programs especially thanks to Bank of
America google.org AT&T fastly and
Novartis but I will remind everyone
including any corporations out there
listening that we continue to run into
deficit so if you in a position to help
out at any scale please think about it
with that I am super excited of
introducing our guest who is someone
that I've always admired and I've I'd
like to believe have become a good
friend over over the last several years
Francis Ford Coppola Francis thanks
thanks so much for joining us my
pleasure to join you so a good place no
a good place to start is you know when
we scheduled this the world was already
in kind of the kovat crisis and you know
I thought we were going to talk a lot
and I think we will talk a lot about you
know learning and especially learning in
times of crisis and you know what is
this doing but obviously there's been
layered on top of kovat
other things in the world you know you
we have the protests and around the the
killing of George Floyd around not just
a country of the world I would love your
view as a storyteller as a filmmaker as
an observer of the human condition you
know what's your lens of what you're
seeing now and you've you've also seen
seen a lot and you're in your lifetime
you know does this have parallels with
other things you've seen or is this is
this different insert well I must say
you know I was born in 1939 so so to me
the big event as I was growing up as I
was a child of four and five and six was
World War two so I was born at a time
when the world was going through one of
the most terrible of all bad things
which is a world war and of course I was
blessed being in America in that we were
never attacked as where our fellows in
all over the world and so this I would
say that this president pandemic is the
most serious crisis that I have
personally as as a more understanding
adult lived through and you know all my
perspective is that you know the human
species as always it's always easy to
say well people are selfish or there's
part of them that's bad and then and it
always has been but you know I don't
believe that to be the case I believe
the story of humanity which has been
certainly going on fifty thousand years
recorded history is only maybe seven
thousand years old but there have been
the the human species is a late comer to
to the the family of creatures that
inhabit the earth and we have changed
quite a bit over that time and and
usually there is some tremendous
influence some innovation or some event
that causes a
a readjustment of what life is like it
goes way back to the time of of
Agriculture when human beings began to
cultivate agriculture for the first time
and suddenly land became a priority so
there was landowners and then with
landowners there were the people who
worked on the land and that evolved into
feudalism and and each face phase of
human development there was always a
reason why things changed all the way up
into say modern time with the Industrial
Revolution it was the the learning how
to make force engines steam engines and
and ultimately mass production and that
changed everything so so this idea to
say that human beings are a certain way
for me is is that true it depends on
what is going to influence what what
what happens and therefore we can
imagine a time when there are other
priorities changed by other things by by
our human ingenuity is constantly
inventing something that changes this
science called economics which everyone
thinks well this is the way it is it's
not the way it is it's ever-changing and
so I can imagine definitely out of out
of even out of this crisis I I see
change I don't hear people talking so
much about oh I'm worth this much money
or I earn that much money I hear them
talking about all my families okay my
family is safe so that I think that
there has been some some positive things
we're learning from from this crisis
together absolutely and and what's your
sense you know the the you know just as
an observer in our country and maybe
around the world but especially in our
country around you know what's around
race issues you know I think we'd like
to believe that there's been progress
but there's also you know it feels like
every now and then we get reminded as
we've been in the last not just last
several weeks but last several years
that you know the things are still
happening that we thought only happened
50 years
I think we are that narrative yeah I
feel that you know we are all immigrants
every there is not an American there is
not anyone living on this continent who
is not an immigrant even the Native
Americans came here maybe fifteen
thousand years ago no there were no
human beings in any part of what we call
the New World
so to refer to them as oh they're new
here they're not really be born here
I heard today on television a lady
berating some young lady of where where
we where were you from well you're not
this is in your own the truth of the
matter is everyone in America is an
immigrant and the immigrants have been a
source of tremendous benefit beyond
calculation that's when one of the
things that gives us such a vitality and
innovation and a certainly African
Americans who who came here not even was
isn't even their will to come here they
were brought here African Americans are
you know I'm an italian-american there
are Chinese Americans there are African
Americans and African Americans have
struggled unfairly against of the the
prejudices that grew up around them
during three hundred years ago and when
you think about it it will take a big
effort to change the four areas that
that that is troublesome one is of
course the criminal justice system two
is the equal opportunity for equal
education three is of course the health
health care and the ability to be
healthy and four in my opinion is child
care and nutrition because these
children have to have good nutrition so
they can learn and they can blossom and
be the the contributors to our society
that that we know is possible and you
say well to do that to really to really
attack those four areas criminal justice
is an enormous job and healthy
an enormous job and it's gonna cost a
great deal of money but that money has
been earned because the african-american
contribution to American culture over
the last three years has earned
trillions of dollars in in revenue from
the the the selling of that culture
which they created jazz and and
literature and dance and and so many
things that have enriched and have it
have enriched our country certainly a
percentage of that as a royalty is worth
spending the the needed money that we
have to do to to revolutionize those
areas of criminal justice health
education and child care and nutrition
the money was earned by what they
contributed and they're entitled to that
money to be spent in those areas as a
royalty right it's a fascinating idea
money as you mentioned contributed over
you know 300 years you know many many
many generations you know just you know
one of the things that that I think we
like to do on on this homeroom is for
any guests because we have a lot of
young people watching their their you
know stage of their life where they're
trying to figure out what to do they
have some things that they're excited
about some things that they might be
feeling less secure about and when they
see a Francis Ford Coppola who's I mean
I don't think I'm you know saying
anything that anyone would disagree with
a filmmaking legend you know they say
well how did how did he become Francis
Ford Coppola so so maybe tell us a
little bit about your own journey
because I think especially something
like filmmaking you know you can go to
film school but it doesn't seem as
obvious of a career track as you know
going to med school or law school how
did you become that and what gave you
the confidence and and did you know how
did you know that you had some of the
creative gifts you know Ernie h-town
from YouTube says thank you mr. Coppola
for the greatest cinema ever and I think
a lot of people would agree with that so
tell us a little bit about that journey
especially when you were young you know
talent is talent is a strange thing and
there's there's two kinds of talent you
can have there's that god-given talent
that you know that we all know those
kids they can just draw a beautiful
pictures and they could and there's no
effort to them or they can sing where
they can dance or they've just been
given the gift the other kind of talent
really you have to work for and one of
the beauties of the of all of these
fields is that even if you didn't get I
did not get that god-given gift I would
say the filmmakers like well Steven
Spielberg clearly just has the knack and
that just was given the talent to do it
plus a lot of work in addition and there
were great directors like William Wyler
who happened to be the nephew of the
owner of Columbia Pictures and got the
chance to do it but he had just a gift
in my case it was I saw talent all
around me my father was a talented
musician and but but I didn't feel I was
given any special anything except I had
enthusiasm and I had a good imagination
and I worked hard and and I just tried
and I tried and I tried to write little
plays when I was a kid and I knew they
were awful but I didn't stop so so
whether you get that god-given gift or
not applying yourself and working hard
and having a dream that one day you'll
be able to do the thing you love it does
work I have seen actors who I remember
from college were terrible and but they
never gave up and they kept trying and
and years later they they started to be
actually brilliant you know so so you
can you can you can either work your way
to what your dream is or you get the
natural gift which sometimes is not even
as good as those those of us who have to
just keep working at it and certainly
that's true of writing or any creative
thing I so I I was a kid who was
extremely good at science and and and I
knew all I understood electricity and I
could make little gadgets I could make
little electric motors or do things like
that and I wanted to be a nuclear
physicist but I had flunked algebra
twice and my father said you can't
a nuclear physicist if you're gonna
flunk flunk algebra and I say my mind
has difficulty unfortunately I looked at
the Khan Academy algebra course and at
my own pace I was able to understand it
I have more of a spatial mind so I won
the geometry medal in school because my
mind thinks as whole pictures doesn't
think as a linear thing so every kid has
the things they're good at naturally and
the things they're less good at and the
trick is to to identify what you're good
at and often it's what you love so I
loved science I wanted to be around
science and technology and unfortunately
I was taken out of school for reasons of
my father's moving around and I went to
about I don't know maybe 20 schools
before college and I would always wander
as a new student I had no friends and I
knew no one and I wasn't doing well in
school
so I would wander I would the teacher
wouldn't even care if I said oh I have
to do a special project I would always
wander to the theatre department because
they always needed boys at that time who
would climb up on the stage and hook up
the lights and from up there with the
lights
I would watch and of course I wanted to
go to the theater department because
that's where the girls were you know the
girls were either in the theater
department or they were at the bar on
the football team while I was sure not
gonna meet them playing football so I I
went they were at least at the theater
department and I wanted I wanted to meet
one if I could or even get to know one
so I was there hanging the lights of the
theater and I would see the teachers
directing the the actors and I thought
well I could do that and so that was
really the reason I became a theater
major and ultimately when I did go to
college I was a theatre student and
that's where I sort of blossomed because
I was doing something that I really
loved which was to do plays and then
from that ultimately the transition came
and I went to film school I could tell
that story if you're interested in why I
chose film school rather that I was
going to go to the Yale Drama School
from my master's degree but something
happened and I went to film school
instead well well now you've you've I
have to ask you what was where I was I
was very poor I had absolutely no money
and and and and and just to eat was like
a major to have a lunch was you know a
major thing and so I would hang around
where they were building the new theater
because I knew I was gonna get to do
plays in that theater and there was a
little theater and there was a sign that
said today only four o'clock we're
showing Sergei Eisenstein's ten days
that shook the world which I had I knew
he was a Russian silent film director
and and so I had nothing to do and and
and I went in there and it will maybe
four people in that little theater and I
saw this silent movie by Eisenstein and
I couldn't believe my eyes you see this
this stuff and even though there was no
air there was no music or anything was
just a silent oh but you could hear it
you could hear the crowds you could hear
the machineguns you could hear
everything because of the way it was
edited it was the first time that I saw
what this magical ability that film has
which we call montage where you take a
shot and put it together with another
shot and make something magical and when
I came out of that theater I said I'm
not going to the Yale Drama School I'm
gonna be a film director like Eisenstein
and I did and I decided to go to the
UCLA film school and my whole life was
changed and that relates to a question
from YouTube eww you says how can you
know not to be too ambitious with your
dreams in life was there any point where
you're thinking maybe I'm you know
filmmaking isn't a guaranteed job how am
I going to pay the bills will I even be
able to make films how did you know you
were being too ambitious yeah I I had no
money
my father was mad at me because I he had
at one point sent me to military school
which I didn't like at all and I ran
away and he had to pay for it even
though I had run away so he didn't want
to support me in college I had no money
I knew no one in the film business I
didn't didn't have a family connection I
did have
the blessing of a creative family my
father was a great musician and I had
uncles who were in music so I had seen
in theatres that kind of stuff but you
know an answer to that young person you
can't be too ambitious you you are given
this unique opportunity to live and and
you should have the most wild wonderful
ambition you can dream up because
anything is possible I'm a good I'm a
good example of that because I was as
poor as you can be I lived I lived I
remember I had 25 cents for a breakfast
I had 40 cents for lunch and I could
sometimes have for dinner a Kraft
macaroni and cheese dinner which in
those days cost about 20 cents so I was
really poor and I went to the most
wonderful film school which was in the
University of California UCLA which was
you know I mean tuition was like 40
dollars a semester or something so which
was a blessing of California at that
time and and and there I was the least
possible person that to to get even in
the movie business and and you know part
of me dreamed of course that I could do
it but the other part thought well maybe
I can become an assistant director or
something then because I did have a sort
of technical ability so I mean every
every person alive is a unique
individual one of a kind if if you're if
you're listening to this there isn't
anyone like you so the the fact that
there's no one like you do what you love
because that's telling you what you
might be good at and and anyway even if
if you're not as good as it is you want
to be you're doing something that you
love doing that's that's you know they
say if you do it you'll love you never
do it they have worked in your life and
it's true you know I would do what I do
I don't even know so most of the time I
don't get paid for what I do I am doing
it because I would do it no matter what
and that's what I think I would tell
young people I remember my daughter
Sophia when she was
young girl she was a very interesting
little precocious young lady and she
always admired fashion and she was a
good painter and she was going to
painting school studying painting and
and she said to me once daddy am I just
a dilettante am I just a girl I'm gonna
be studying painting but I'll never
probably be really a great painter I
like fashion I like photography I like
stories what should I do and I said do
everything you love why because if you
do what you love you're going to learn
about all the things you love and who
knows what you're gonna be in five years
you may decide to be something but if
you were doing the things you loved I
bet you that they will be useful and
then four or five years later she made a
little short film you can see it on the
net it's called like the star and she
was just with her high school friends
and you could see when you made that
that she was a born movie director and
all of her interests fashion photography
storytelling painting all helped her be
a film director so even if you're not
sure what your profession is gonna be
still do the things you love because
there is no doubt that if you do those
things they will be useful when it
finally is clear to you what your
profession that you wish is and then and
and and you'll have the benefit of all
of the things you were interested in no
that's that's super powerful you know
the question from Facebook here Jeanne
Nicole says did you have a person in
your life that helped you believe you
can do anything you want it sounded like
Sophia had you and probably others as a
teacher it's a genie as a teacher as a
teacher I strive to make sure I tell
each student so yeah who in your own
life and actually maybe who and other
people's life have you played that role
because I know there have been several
oh when I was a very bad student I
should have defended myself because so
my father getting good grades and doing
well in school he had come from a
neighborhood in the sort of area in New
York were where the boys either became
hoodlums or professional musicians or
doctors
and lawyers there was a split so he he
hated a hoodlum mentality someone who
didn't do well in school but at the same
time he took me out of school every six
months and I was always in a different
school sometimes even in a far distant
area like I would be going to school in
New York and then suddenly I'm going to
junior high school in California well
California in New York was as different
more different than any two places on
earth is today
I remember being ridiculed in school in
New York because I was eating a avocado
because people in New York had never
seen an avocado that's how different it
was so so my feeling is that you know
once so I was then I was not in good
with my family my brother was a
brilliant student and and I was a
terrible student but my mother did
something good for me my father didn't
take me too seriously when I said oh I
want to be a director and stuff of plays
but my mother said listen if you're
interested in being a director I'll give
you enough money that you can go to New
York on the outskirts of New York I'll
let you go to a matinee of a play every
week and so every Wednesday I would go
in the subway or whatever the method
where I was living to the city and I
would see a Broadway matinee you know
which probably cost $8 was a lot of
money but she gave me the money to do
that and I think you know that was a
wonderful thing she a gift she gave me
also in UCLA I met a professor who was
one of the only women movie directors
Hollywood ever had her name was ELISA
funny Dorothy Arthur and she directed
many many many big Hollywood films with
great stars like Katharine Hepburn and
Joan Crawford and and she was a major
Hollywood director and the only woman
for many years who was and and and and
she she was very encouraging to me and
there was a time I can remember one
night I was broke I was
miserable I was lonely you know and she
came out and and and out of the bungalow
that where the film school was in UCLA
and and she said to me she said you know
you'll make it
I've been around a long time and I know
you will and she left and I was ready to
quit but that word of this one teacher I
said wow she was she was a great movie
director and if she says that that I I'm
gonna make it God maybe I shouldn't I
wanted to quit and go get back to New
York and maybe see if I could get a job
as a stage manager something but but
that little voice of encouragement
helped me a lot I think one thing in the
second part of your questions how is
that American film directors have been
very good about supporting each other
and helping each other
I mentioned Steve Steven Spielberg he
has sponsored so many young directors
and made it possible for them to have
their careers and even I and my career
took a very bright much younger student
whom I had met and and you know wanted
to work with I thought he was so bright
and and I said I'm gonna try to help you
get to make your first film and that was
George Lucas who of course made Star
Wars in American Graffiti and is you
know as a legend but he was the skinny
16 any about D how old was he when I met
him maybe just 20 years old and and
became you know at first this assistant
but very quickly not an assistant more
of an associate and and and there have
been opportunities to to give a helping
hand or encourage even even the great
one of the great all-time directors
today probably the greatest living
working director Martin Scorsese was it
was a kid a younger director that I that
I tried to be helpful to I remember I
got him the job too
the film he made with Ellen Burstyn
Alice doesn't live here anymore so uh uh
it's part of it's like being a tree and
if you're not planting new young trees
around you there won't be a forest and
what did you see in a young George Lucas
or Martin Scorsese I'm guessing that
there were other I don't know exactly
where you are in your career arc but I'm
guessing by that point you were starting
to get relatively established or known
what what did you see in them probably
there were other people who would love
mentorship for me what what what spark
did you see in them that said yeah I
think they're gonna if you if you
scratch a filmmaker what comes out is no
matter how old they are no matter you
know if you scratch the skin a little
out pours enthusiasm to to hear George
Lucas talk about film he would get so
excited about you know you take that
shot and you put that together with that
shot and you get something that you
didn't imagine could happen there's such
an outpouring of love and enthusiasm for
the cinema to this day Martin Scorsese
is the best film teacher I think on
earth you I would recommend very
seriously anyone interested in movies to
get a documentary series that Martin
made called that my voyage my Italian my
Italian voyage which is a multiset in
which he discusses from the beginning to
end the Italian cinema and goes into
every director and what they did you
come out after seeing that a you know so
much about how the cinema evolved and
develop but more important you just want
to make a film and that and that's great
you know that's what young filmmaker you
know when I was a young theatre student
I had three heroes that I just I mean
they were like Untouchables it was of
course Elia Kazan it was Marlon Brando
and Tennessee Williams and and they
represented two with a theatre student
of the 50s you know the ultimate and of
course I was blessed to have been able
to meet each of
but it's good to have a hero of someone
who if you're a writer of whose books
you just admire so much or if it's a
dance a dancer who inspires you or a
composer or whoever it is a songwriter
Carole King whoever it is you love and
it's alright to even imitate them
because you can't imitate the mess the
beauty of it in other words you could
try to write a song like Carole King but
it goes through you and it comes out
different and that's what you want
I remember once reading a note about
Balzac the great French writer and
someone said no the young writers are
are taking your writing and they're
copying it and Balzac said oh I want
them to I want to do that's why I do it
because when they take it they make it
their own it means I'll live through
them forever
and and and and and this idea that oh of
course plagiarism is is wrong when you
when you take something someone else
wrote and say you wrote it but to be
inspired and try to do something like
the person who inspires you whether it's
anything music film dance that's okay
because you can't just copy it in you
you are such a unique creation yourself
that it'll come out differently and
little by little you'll start to
understand the difference and as it
becomes clear to you that becomes your
voice and you go on and it becomes more
and more beautiful and then some young
person will steal from you and you want
them to it's there for them that's super
powerful and you know one thing that I
think it comes through and even just
your narrative and what you see in
others but you know the spark this
curiosity I don't think probably the
world fully appreciates just how much
you have that in you for context you
know the first time well the last time
we've seen we saw each other priek Ovid
you you you said yeah I would love to
meet but you've got to teach me calculus
tell us a little bit about your love for
learning III think you're kind of
infectious when you talk about that
well that's very important because I
think if I could give
this the subject of education my two
cents be it the teachers wonderful
teachers and less wonderful teachers the
students the wonderful students the less
wonderful students what I would say to
them that I have learned is that the
secret to why we want to learn is
because it's pleasure that learning is
one of the greatest pleasures you can
have and and and and if you if the
students could understand that sure
there's lots of reason you learn because
then you'll become more wise and you'll
be able to get a profession or you'll be
a doctor or you'll make your parents
proud or you'll be able to make money
money all those things the real reason
to want to learn is because the more you
learn and learn how to learn the more
pleasure you get and and I always had an
example I think I even hell yeah have it
here why is that true you know because
you think of human beings they were born
in the mud you know we suddenly so where
are we what is this where am I is gonna
get it's cold I'm cold I'm hungry I
better find something to eat so human
beings just ran into a bunch of puzzles
that they didn't know the answers to but
because we're gifted with this wonderful
ability to think and the tradition to
think and ultimately we learn how to
think that we're able to solve the
puzzles and it's it's a great pleasure
to solve puzzles and I always make this
I have it here I have this example all
the kids know this puzzle this is the
two nails that yeah go like that and if
you have one of these you say well how
do you get these two nails apart and and
some kids can just figure it out
immediately and others don't but if
someone says look at the way to do it is
you line it up so that you see how my oh
yeah
you line it up so it's like this and
it's pointing up and then you go like
that and oh this is gonna work you go
you go like this twist it around
I know how to do this wait a second
my whole point is being you line them up
like that and then you twist it around
like that so I failed
this shows a learning process we're all
we're all on this debate you do it like
that and then you go around like that or
is it around like that
or no it's up like the kids are laughing
at me because they know how to do it
anyway I'll know you put it up like that
then you take one around I'm so close
anyway it's great pleasure to learn that
how to solve this puzzle and later I'll
do it again
but the learning how to do anything is
my point is it's a pleasure if I had
been able to teach you how to do this
stupid puzzle I would have been happy
and we've given me pleasure but learning
everything is a lot of fun and that's
the reason why we we go to school and we
learn is that because of all this the
sub reasons that they tells us because
it's a lot of fun to do know and kudos
to you Francis because I think you know
in real time on on live I guess live
stream to try it shows you know a growth
mindset uh not not a fear of failure and
I think we all want to go and try to you
can't you can't have a few like failure
if you have a fear of failure you won't
do anything that's right yeah and also a
failure is is one of the steps of
success because when you learn what not
to do then you don't do that again and
you skip that so that's that's of equal
step towards success if you make a movie
that's a bad movie that doesn't work
that doesn't uplift the audience or
engrossed them then you think about it a
lot and and and you say well next time
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna make those
mistakes someone someone tricked this
they made it so I can't do it I know one
of my teeth one of my kids know that
they bent the nails a little bit too
much you know IIIi would be remiss I'm
getting a lot there's a lot of questions
from a lot of film film buffs here as
you could imagine you've poked out right
I'll try less talkative and I'll try oh
no this is wonderful no no this is and
keep solving the nail puzzle you know
Emmy there's a lot of questions about I
mean people are asking what's your
favorite horror films people are asking
about some of the things that you know
gene ham from facebook asks you know and
Mike Michael Corleone pops the hole in
the orange and sucks the juice out of it
it's kind of a metaphor for how he
treats life you know is that stuff you
came up with was it in the script was it
something the actor came up with
I'd love I'd love your views on that oh
very good again you know the metaphor of
the orange in The Godfather you know I
basically saw the oranges around I
didn't have an idea about this could be
a symbol of anything I just didn't take
the orange you know or like when I put
the cat in Marlon Brando's hand I took
other words it seemed to be an
opportunity to to use what was around
and after a while then I when I edited
the movie I I began to understand that
that the orange said something a lot of
times when you're working on something
you're sort of half in a trance and
you're doing it because it feels right
to you or it seems to be logical
although I do have a rule when I'm
making a film I always try to know what
the overall theme is in one sentence
like in The Godfather the theme was
succession in in Apocalypse Now the
theme was morality so if I know what the
big picture is when they ask me a lot of
questions of well you know a director
just answers questions all that should
she be in a dress or in slacks should
she have long hair or short hair sure
she drive a sports car or said then and
you just say off the top of your head
yeah long hair yeah a dress but when you
don't know how to answer it then I
always say well what's the theme and
then for example the movie I made the
conversation they were asking me what
kote he should wear and I said well he's
really not a detective so it shouldn't
be like a Humphrey Bogart coat and one
of the coats they showed me was a
raincoat and was transparent and I said
well the theme of the conversation is
privacy so let me give him a transparent
raincoat sometimes if you don't know the
decision if you ask yourself what the
theme is it will suggest what the
decision should be so there are lots of
tricks that you can learn that's that's
the super powerful you know I had my
name it my favorite horror film of all
time Multi vism you know when you get to
the subject of favorite films there's
always people who come up with all my 10
favorite films that is so absurd you
could come up with a thousand favorite
build because the cinema which has only
existed for a hundred forty years was
blessed with the most wonderful
masterpieces even in the 30s when movies
were silent there were already 10 20 30
masterpieces so when you ask what is
your favorite horror film you could say
Nosferatu of munna which was a silent
film it's a silent version of a kind of
Dracula story that's a great one or you
could say alien that was unbelievably
scary and horrible but other what is
there there probably four or five really
or you could talk of Japanese films the
film of Mizoguchi who gets ooh that's
really beautiful
so cinema is so filled with a bounty II
that you can just enjoy for your whole
lifetime seeing the great works that
were made and they tend to make you want
to make one too because it seems like
such a wonderful feel the cinema it's
it's it's it's truly one of the
beautiful all the arts are and and I of
course like to encourage young people to
consider going in the arts because their
parents aren't their parents as they'd
all become an accountant or become a
lawyer or become a doctor but partly is
because their parents want them to be
able to make a living and the truth of
the matter is the arts is a wonderful
book way to make a living
what they call today intellectual
property which is when you make a book
or you make a painting and stuff that
that's very valuable because it's such a
beautiful thing so I think young people
should consider being artists it's it's
a you will love doing it be it will make
you you will be making other people
happy and giving them something that
will enrich their lives and and it's I
think it's one of the great professions
to choose you know more and more as we
go into the future there's going to be
less and less jobs this is not
necessarily bad which it means is that
people are going to be able to do more
what they love rather than the toil
particle you know the work that you hate
machines and AI and other things are
gonna do that and and you say what about
the money and eventually you know I
believe this is crazy but just like
today we all pay taxes in the future the
cover the state will give you will pay
you the taxes because you are a citizen
and you're entitled because more and
more nonliving what Aristotle called
nonliving machines are going to be doing
the work the toil I shouldn't call it
work work is fun right and one last I
mean that we could talk for hours I know
we're already over time but maybe just a
good capstone you know there's a lot of
young people watching it is around
graduation time you know what what
advice would you give to them or another
way to think about it if you were them
today what yeah what would you want to
work on what what would you want to know
well I think this is gonna I know it's a
it's a tough time and people are scared
about the future I see the future even
the pandemic as teaching us some good
lessons that we should value as to
what's really important if you ask
people today what's really important
it's mud that my family is okay that the
people I love are okay that my friends
are okay that that we're we're
it's less so I'm gonna be a billionaire
I have a new word by the way better than
billionaire I call it sufficient there a
sufficient there having enough for what
you need you know who you don't want to
just pile up a lot of excess stuff I
can't believe that the so-called 1% that
they talk about that have all those
hundreds of billions of dollars I can't
believe that they're any happier than
some really happy person they remember
we know you know thinking you're gonna
have money makes you happy anticipating
having money makes you happy having it
as a whole
those people are miserable you know
because all they're doing is managing
worrying about losing it and stuff
that's not happiness that's not even a
smart thing to do the smart thing to do
is have a lot of friends have a lot of
capability being able to do things and
and having the freedom to be able to do
it having a great education you should
be I think that we should go to be
educating ourselves go to school or
being involved in some school thing for
entire lives I do it I'm am 81 and
learning is my greatest source of
pleasure I'm reading a book right now
about fungi that I tell you I always
take good notes when I read because I
may want to remember what I read so many
books I don't you know you forget what
you what you learn so I take good notes
I can barely get through two paragraphs
of this book without underlining is I'm
underlining the whole book cause every
when you talk about the subject of fungi
which of course is I think I forget what
that's ism is called when you study that
it is so amazing that it is so different
than we think of how these networks work
and how they think and it is just
utterly a joy to learn something every
time at night when I go to bed I always
read before I fall asleep and I always
learn so much and that's my real
pleasure of life is learning and I would
tell the young person you're talking
about never stop learning never stop
studying there always be learning more
and more not because it's useful but
because it's pleasurable
I love that and as I consider myself a
very lucky sufficient dare so from one
sufficient air to another thank you
wherever this efficient air cloud which
is which is an honor to because not
everyone has sufficient Airness
definitely but if more people were
content to be sufficient heirs
instead of billionaires then we could
all be sufficient heirs and that's the
goal right right losing and we wouldn't
lose all the individuality I mean there
was still you know like I made it I made
a dumb remark at people who I'd actually
didn't make the remark I was asked at a
press conference if I agreed with
something one of my colleagues said that
Marvel pictures were sort of not real
cinema and I said of course they're
cinema they cinema that some of them are
just made by wonderful talented people
and the ingenuity they show but the
problem is is what the goal and and and
and in the economics that I read there's
the idea that if you make a lot of money
doing things that are good for Humanity
that's just that's it's good like if you
if you did something that just gave
people a lot of pleasure or everything
you're entitled to to be rewarded but to
make money that doesn't contribute
anything is despicable you know I said
that not about Marvel Pictures I said it
about just anyone who does anything that
he just makes a lot of money that
doesn't do any good for anyone except
him I said that was despicable so the
headline was Coppola thinks Marvel
pictures are despicable which I never
said haha and I don't think it's true
but boy did I have a hassle with that
one so because sometimes you know it's
the headlines that argue rather than
what is said any rate III still do
believe that I believe that you know
your work if it benefit you if you gain
some some well from it or some privilege
if you you know as I said my friend
George Lucas think of how many young
people he made happy with the Star Wars
films what he gave to them and
besides those people usually when they
get a lot of dough then he like
Georgie's giving it all away anyway for
education and stuff and and as it should
be so yes be if we were all sufficient
heirs there would be no note no poverty
no well that's a powerful statement to
end on well well thank you so much
Francis I hope I hope we can do this
again I'm pretty confident the entire
community that's watching would love
this to continue for hours but thank you
so much
it's my pleasure in my honor and you
know I never spend any time with with
students I consider myself a student as
you know and I never I never spiit spend
time with him if I could hear them and
stuff I learned every bit as much from
them as that they could possibly learn
from me and and my respect to you what
you've invented saliz's is really
important and wonderful helps so many
students get through stuff that they
think they can't understand and you
teach them that they can't understand
thank you appreciate that so it's so
much maybe we will do some videos
together in the near future okay yeah
ciao well well thanks everyone for
joining as you can tell I went way over
because frankly it was just a
fascinating conversation and I guess we
don't really have a hard stop I hope I
hope Francis I didn't keep him from
something else but as you can tell
Francis is the type of person that you
wish you could you know have multiple
evenings chatting about pretty much any
any topic but hopefully you enjoyed that
is it today is Friday already so and I'm
actually going to be on a staycation
next week you know people said where are
you going on your vacation I'm like
Mountain View which is where I live
but so we won't we won't be having the
live stream next week but the week after
will be back so thanks everyone for
joining in and see you then
you
you